what is going on subscribers and others
welcome to the second video of object
detection inside of grand theft auto
using the tensor flow object detection
AP i-- in this video what we're gonna do
is build on the last video in the last
video we just got object detection
working in grand theft auto and now what
we're gonna go ahead and do is try to
detect cars in the distance basically
and then try to figure out some way to
calculate their distance from us like
are they far enough away that they're
not a problem or are they look really
close and then from there we can build
on top of that to detect when a vehicle
maybe it's too close and either take
evasive action or just display like a
warning or something like that so that's
what we're gonna be doing now from the
last video since I was recording and
noticing frame drops I went ahead and
just kind of changed something in here
you can designate how much vram the the
session wants to take up here by adding
these GPU options and then when you run
your actual session in the config
parameter there you can add in some
configuration information so I'm going
to try to set it lower I might even go
with like 50% I'm gonna try 70% right
now and see if that works so so let's go
ahead and get into the code so at least
on the object detection API if you know
for tensorflow
that little mini-series people were
asking like how do I get that those the
information and how do I like you know
continue working on that and at least to
me I think I feel like it's fairly
obvious right here you have your boxes
here you've got your scores your classes
and then you can also see here down here
you've got the actual return from the
detection of the session of boxes scores
and classes so if you want to continue
playing with this I mean this is this is
where it begins and then if you want to
play with like how it's actually
visualized on screen you can play with
this function here so basically what
we're going to do is before the in show
we're just gonna work right underneath
the busy till dot visualize boxes and
labels and all that and we're basically
gonna start iterating through any one of
these would work I'm just gonna iterate
through boxes I am sure there's a better
way to do all of the things I'm about to
do this is just an example of proof of
concept
so anyways what I'm going to say is for
I be in and numerate boxes zero so boxes
is like an array of or array it's an
array inside of another array I don't
know why that was so difficult for me to
get out
but anyways box is zero begins the
iteration through all of the boxes and
the boxes contain the coordinates I
forget I think it's like x1y1 x2y2 but I
honestly forget the order I think that's
it anyway we'll get there so find out if
we're right or not
so anyways for IB and enumerate box is
zero
now what we want to go ahead and do is
check the classes of those boxes so in
this case we're trying to watch out for
cars so so how do you detect the date
like let's say you've got a flat 2d
image right
how could you detect the distance of an
object in that image at least for me I
believe the only way you could possibly
do that is if you knew the size of that
object beforehand so you can detect
distances like so for example the
average car I don't know three feet four
feet wide I really don't know let's go
with like four feet wide maybe an SUV
might even be five feet or something I
don't know but let's just say you know
it's somewhere between four and five
feet wide okay but so if you wanted to
detect a car you know it's four to five
feet wide so then if on your little
image depending on how wide it actually
is on the image you could actually did
you could actually calculate the exact
distance of that object if you knew the
exact size of that object unfortunately
we don't know the exact size of every
single car in Grand Theft Auto but we
don't need to know we just need to kind
of have a general idea like okay these
objects are about these sizes so for
example for a car
we're going to do is we're just gonna
basically measure the amount of pixels
in between you know from X x1 to x2 how
wide is that and then from there we can
get a relative determination of how far
away that object actually is but you
that rel it like for a car we're gonna
wind up using about like 0.1 okay ten
percent of the you know the pixels that
are taking up the screen let's say and
actually we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna end up changing that functionality
but let's just say at 10 percent if the
car is taking up 10 percent of the
pixels on the screen and we're you know
traveling at a good speed now it's a
threat or we could say if the car is
taking up 30 percent of the pixels you
know width wise on the screen we're in
trouble
but that number would be different for
say a wedding a pedestrian I mean if the
pedestrians taking up 30% of everything
that's on screen you just hit that
pedestrian so it just depends on what
the object is and how wide it is anyway
what we're going to do now is so we're
gonna ask if classes 0 hi because just
like boxes they're like a raised inside
of a raised if class is 0 I is equal to
3 which is a car or classes 0 well let's
just do this
will detect probably three things here
and even this might not work very well
but anyway three three six or eight so
what car is three six is a bus and eight
is a truck and you might be like syntax
how do you know that so the way I did
that or I found that out is let me just
navigate there inside of the object
detection models yes I'm sure I think
was in training no is it in data I
forget which one of ten it's in one of
these directories if you go to dude I
can't find it now if you looked if you
look in the actual ipython notebook
you'll find wherever it's listing like
again if you go to the tensor flow
object detection tutorial remember those
configuration files I can't even find
the configuration file I really want to
find it for you guys so I can at least
you show it to you but I'm not finding
it I'm gonna deleted it or something or
I'm blind well both anyway in the
configuration file it links to where all
the classes are just like when we wrote
our own classes so I just went there and
figured out what was the class for car
truck and bus but there's 90 possible
classifications so there's a lot of
different things you could add but I
figure kind of that car truck bus they
all have to fit in standard American
lanes so they're probably about the same
issue with cars are gonna be less width
obviously than like trucks especially a
semi truck or something like that but
generally they're the same plus to avoid
a truck that's bigger so you probably
give it more more space anyway so anyway
continuing along next we're gonna ask if
score scores zero I is greater than 0.5
so we're doing this again because if you
can't see it here but if you went and
actually go into the visito and then
read this function one of the the
parameters although it's set as a
default is like the minimum score
required to draw it so you might notice
that none of the objects ever have a
score or less than 50% well that's
because it just doesn't draw anything
that has less than a 50% but actually if
you lower that threshold you would be
astonished by how many objects are
actually being detected on your screen
it's it's a large list so you can change
that but anyways but if we just iterate
through these you'll get tons of objects
that have less than 50% and we don't we
just don't really want those you can
feel free to tweak this a little more if
you like especially any especially the
further away you get from real realistic
depictions of whatever you're trying to
detect you might have to change the
score a little bit but anyway now we're
going to measure the distance so the
approximate underscore distance we I
could also call this relative distance
because we're not actually going to
convert this to any metric or imperial
units I'm just going to use a relative
distance you can feel free to write a
conversion if you'd like something
that's fairly realistic I'd love to see
it because it gets hard as things kind
of travel off into the distance and I
thought about doing it and I was like
there's really no point because we're
really we don't care about how things
are like way off in the distance we
really just want a lot of granularity as
we get real close so how we could do it
is basically we're just going to say
boxes and this will be the the x and the
y so I think it's actually like a Y and
then X let's do boxes I know boxes 0 I
and then this is 3 minus
one if I'm wrong someone yell at me but
I'm pretty sure that'll work I mean the
why would I mean in theory like the
height of the thing would work as well
but then trucks would be severely like
trucks and and like semi trucks or
actual trucks and SUVs they really vary
more by height than they do by width but
anyways we'll see how that works
so that would be a way to measure
approximate distance but this this could
be so this is this comes out in
percentage so what's one more thing I
wanted to bring up so so the boxes are
not in pixel numbers they're actually
again in relative so it's from basically
zero to one so it will be like point one
or point six if it's perfectly in the
middle of the screen it will be 0.55
point five so so so this will return
this could return in theory a long float
and we don't really want that so what
we're gonna go ahead and do is we're
gonna we would round it this and then
we'll just round to one now the other
thing we'd like to do is let's go ahead
and encase this in parenthesis and then
we'll do a one minus that number and
then this way because like this way
would have been a lot larger as it got
closer and but if we do one minus the
difference here it'll be smaller as it
gets closer so that's just a little more
intuitive if you ask me okay
so once we have that what we're going to
go ahead and do I mean
I think that's right let me just make
sure that closes off yeah okay
now to give it a little more granularity
as we get close another option we have
is like to encase it like this one and
then to the power of four or something
like that that'll give us a little more
granularity cool so good enough we can
kind of tweak this as we go on we'll
just kind of see how this how this pans
out for us now what I want to do is we
want to calculate basically where is
where's like the middle point of this
this object so we want to we want to do
this for a variety of reasons one I'm
gonna use it to as a place to display
what's the distance of the car but also
we want to know where that car is like
where's the middle point of that car so
we can determine is this car actually in
our sights is it far off to the right or
far off to the left or is it something
we're about to hit and if we wanted to
avoid it if it's more to our right then
we could turn left or something like
that so we we kind of want to know the
midpoint of that vehicle
so the way that we're going to do that
is I'm going to say mid underscore X is
equal to and in fact I'm gonna just take
this here it's equal to two the x's but
we're actually just gonna add them to
each other so it's equal to those yeah
yeah yeah divided by 2 and then 4 mid
why I'm just gonna copy paste mid Y and
this will be to 0 okay so so this will
give us
yeah that's fine so so this will give us
the middle point of everything so now
what we're gonna do
finally is we're going to add a a CV to
dot put text and then where do we want
to put that text we're going to put it
to image underscore numpy and then what
we're gonna do is we don't really need
the string formatting but I'm going to
do it
a px distance and we're rounding that
but what you could do is if you did
convert it to like some other unit is
you can say like meters or something
like that otherwise you really could
just remember this to string then what
we're going to do is where are we gonna
put that so again these are not pixel
values there are percentages this is a
percentage as well so but CV 2 dot X
doesn't want a percentage it once exact
pixel values and we've decided that the
screen that we're gonna show is an 800
by 450 so to do that what we're gonna
say is this one's XY z-- in tuple form
so I'm gonna say int it's gonna be its
by an int want to make sure you do into
it won't take a float because you can't
have like a half of a pixel so we're
gonna say mid x times 800 and then int
mid yep mid Y times 450 make sure yeah
it wasn't off screen so and then we can
pick the font so we'll just do CV to dot
all caps font underscore Hershey honors
or simplex and then what we're gonna do
is for the size will do 0.7 the color
will do 255 255 255 and then line width
will be a 2 so that will put the size or
the approximate relative distance on the
car hopefully somewhere in or near the
box having to be perfect so it's gonna
start right in the middle and then go
off to the side but it's just for
debugging purposes I don't really care
to make it that beautiful
and then finally we are almost done
the final thing we're gonna say is gift
a px distance is less than or equal to
well just sort of 0.5 and then we'll
kind of see how we're doing so it's nice
that are equal to 0.5 that object is
close but that object if it's like off
to our side like a little bit like if
it's like near our like front quarter
panel of the car it's gonna be huge but
we're missing it we're totally fine
so so we wouldn't we wouldn't want to
always warn just because that object is
very large and it's close we only want
to warn if it's in our you know our
trajectory so we're gonna ask one more
question that's gonna if mid X is
greater than 0.3 and mid X is less than
0.7 if that is the case we've got a
problem
then what we want to do is display a
warning or something like that so I'm
actually gonna just copy this line here
copy paste I just want to get rid of
these tabs so what we're gonna do is on
image numpy yeah then our message is
just gonna be warning we're gonna
display it hmm we could display it on
the vehicle but it kind of neat I was
gonna display it in the corner but part
of me wants to display it on the vehicle
we could display it at minus 50 maybe
this should work right we'll see cool
and then our color we're gonna make it
this is CV two's working in BGR so 0 0
255 would be all red to fine it's a
warning let's make it 3 unless they get
one point out
it's probably this isn't gonna be pretty
I'm just warning you in advance it will
be pretty okay so what I'm gonna do now
is save this and I'm gonna try to run it
I'm gonna go ahead and pause because it
takes a while for everything kind of
fire up and we might hit an error or
something like that so I'm gonna pause
while I start this up and then I'll get
like a vehicle or something like that
and then I'll resume once we were
running all right let's see if our are
70% GPU usage works better so we're in a
car we're detecting cars at distance
that's pretty cool as it was passing on
her sided and it wasn't a problem but
then it became a problem no warning for
that guys we passed let's go ahead and
head towards these cars we got a warning
he was probably a little too late but it
worked my minus 50 actually was a pretty
good distance there yeah those warnings
are way too late I just tried to brake
like as soon as I saw them it didn't
work but what we can do is just since
that guy is no longer with us we can use
this car for an example which is
apparently a truck but that's okay so
it's right in front of us and we're
getting the warning but then this car to
our left is in bounds but it wasn't
given this a warning now he's gone
because he we weren't gonna hit him same
thing with this car here so this guy if
we continue to turn and maybe face this
car
whoops hit him my bad my bad homie now
that original cars not a problem now
it's this car and if we continue to turn
a bit both of these will probably could
be a warning maybe sort of
if I think that there we go now both
cars are a warning so pretty cool that
we can detect other cars detect kind of
some sort of have some sort of collision
warning system and all that it also
looks like the frame rates are better
that works so 70 percent seems to be
good enough to recording so just
continue doing that so might come my GPU
okay pretty cool but as I was saying
before that's not all we can do with the
object detection API there's obviously a
lot of stuff that we can do within the
kind of self-driving car format but one
of the other things I'd really like to
do is at least for the stream I'd like
to be able to have it you know you know
full circle we're on that self-driving
car stream if the agent for whatever
reason Charles gets out of his vehicle
he has no way to get back into a vehicle
he doesn't know how to steal a car so I
thought it'd be kind of cool to use
something like this where we know where
the cars are we know they're about
distance could we write some code that
accurately goes to the car and steals
the car if we're on foot so that's what
I'm going to do in the next probably two
tutorials so you can stay tuned for that
if you've got questions comments
concerns or whatever up to the point of
this tutorial let me know I'll do my
best to help you out otherwise I will
see you in the next tutorial possibly
it's impossible to pause this while I'm
in the game